about refunds formulas so thank you sure
bunk is thank you for inviting me and
thank you my doing I'm here and
organizing this a great workshop you've
been really very interesting so what I'm
going to talk about I'm going to talk
about the randomization of polynomially
identity testing this is a joint work
with the annual minimum so I guess many
of these problems do not need
introduction in fact it's a good thing
that many of the results that I'm going
to quote here I can just point out to
the people in the audience so we'll see
how it goes but anyway I have a lot of
things to talk about and I'd rather have
more questions and discussion that
finish the slides because as I think
what we're doing here so I'm going to
give some introduction talk about
previous results and trying to find some
people in the audience talk about the
model and particularly advanced
polynomials and finally make stock as
much as the time permits talk about the
proof techniques so well the problem I
guess needs no introduction because it
has been repeated so many times already
but for consistency I'm one to do it the
problem is were given a polynomial in
some sections representation I want to
know the polynomial is identically 0 so
as I'm sure all of you know to make this
problem interesting we have to specify a
few things so you have to make some
things clear which I'm going to do so
the first thing is I guess the model of
computation so something against which I
suppose needs to introduction but I'm
going to do it anyway we're talking
about arithmetic formulas so briefly an
arithmetic formula is a tree directed
tree from the input to the output when
the leaves are labeled by variables and
few constants and then there are this
internal gates that are labeled by
arithmetic operation so then you start
at the bottom and apply it and here you
get to the end so this is for example
what this formula computes and this is
again something that we all rely on in
many context but in this talk actually
will not be talking much about formula
I'll be talking in black box setting so
what is a black box setting is actually
the case where we cannot see the for
class so we can only access the formula
by sending inputs and outputs so there
is a black box that has a formula inside
but we don't get to see the
the only way we can do it the only thing
we can do is that send some inputs
evaluate the formula and get some output
this is this famous black box scenario
so just for some technical reason again
I'm not actually going to mention it if
you actually want to make it right to
make it efficient you have to assume
that you should be able to allow to
query this formula on some extension
field but again don't worry about that
this is just a technicality so with
respect to this setting and natural
object of study is what's called a
heating set so what's a heating set is a
set of points such that so heat except
for a Class C the set of points such
that every nonzero polynomial in this
class evaluates to some nonzero point on
that set and if you think about it for a
moment if you want to do black box PT
this is actually the only thing you can
do right you can start querying your
polynomial until the first time we get a
nonzero value then you stop alright so
this is why essentially black box PhDs
he thinks that are the same thing and we
should think about them like that
so the goal is kinda to find a small
heating set for some small nice class of
polynomials computed by small for most
for example so probably doesn't need to
tell it but regardless this problem has
applications to various other problems
in complexity or an algorithm design
like for example people not identity so
I don't know if you know if people notch
actually proved it in a brute force way
but now if you have the PID Oracle you
can actually verify it easily or quickly
right and we have some results so get on
hello and we have you know a meeting
which the point is this results the core
component is that some some form of PID
inside them which are the randomized for
example in this work and I can go on and
the IP because P space the PCP theorem
the things that talked about the first
day these things that roughly talked
about before that I can go on and on and
on and pretty much recreate the entire
workshop but I think you get it right so
this is the problem has context many
other things that they discuss here so
what do we know about this problem so
kind of if we assume that we can use
random number generators randomness then
the problem has a very nice cute I think
solution which is due to Spartans apple
which is just a value 80 or polynomial
at random point and that going to do the
job now as many things of this kind is
does not it gives us a very efficient
randomized algorithm but does not give
us a deterministic one but it suggests
that maybe one exists so this is sort of
one of the sort of the goal here we'll
try to find that line of researches
tries to find the true monistic parity
algorithms for various classes of work
so one question some of you may ask is
if you kinda go look at the you know the
sighing outside is like the lower bounds
workshop so what are we doing here
discussing algorithm so an answer to
that question was given by Valentin
Russell who showed that the trim in East
CIT implies superpolynomial lower bounds
from arithmetic or boolean otherwise and
this and one big motivation to study it
subsequently the world all kinds of
words by a grovyle a grovyle and veena
that make this connection more tight for
example if you get have a black box be
80 you can get explicit arithmetic lower
bounds and then there are all kinds of
trade off in these particular cases and
the point is all the lower bounds that
we get here are explicit and very strong
and I guess if we ask all of you in this
audience all of them are going to
believe that these lower bounds that we
get should kinda hold unconditionally
yet they have been the holy grail of
this line of research a computational
complexity so we all believe in them we
know how to do it but somehow we can we
cannot see the proof of them right so
what you can look at this in two ways
one way to say well this line of
research is complicated complexity is
complicated life is hard let's go into
subject projects like machine learning
for example or alternatively you can say
well perhaps studying more about PID
could shed some light on this lower
bounds on and on the flip side learning
about lower bounds can inform us in
terms of designing better algorithms
which I think has been repeated this
this manner has been repeated throughout
this workshop many many many times so
this is sort of what we're trying to do
all try to learn study PID and see how
we can learn things from that so as I'm
sure you know if the problem is hard we
start looking at them special cases so
one such special case one such
restriction was due to what's called the
depth so the first interesting case was
sparse polynomials this corresponds to
polynomials of the apps to have
additional multiplication actually this
is the case I pretty much know
everything about the kind of studied
through the next stop was depth three
formulas so these are formulas where we
have another layer so it's addition
multiplication addition and we have a
big line of work this is just a partial
list and many of these acronyms again
belong to the people who sit in this
room and the neck
that was the EPS for which in a sense
sort of the last stop because it was
shown at depths for the in general forms
kinda equivalent to the general case so
this was like a big line of research in
terms of looking at bounded depth
another line of research was pertaining
to what's called read so read means we
look at the formula and somehow restrict
the number of appearances of a variable
in some ways and again this is just a
partial list actually in the recent
years I could add another section of
this result so as the name suggests this
type of work also talks about this line
about restricting forever about
restricting the written let me define
that question so as I've said the goal
is to find algorithms for some sound for
some particular classes of polynomials
and one such class one such high level
classes class of multi linear
polynomials well you all know what it is
it means there is no like cancellations
no like squares and stuff like that so
multi linear polynomials are important
the permanent is multi linear determine
this multi linear and so on so what we
know that if we want to hit all multi
linear polynomials actually has a very
nice solution the boolean cube so good
news and bad news this is the heating
set for almost linear polynomials the
bad news is that if you want to heat all
multi linear polynomials you have to pay
the high price of that so it's not
something feasible so we have to make
some structure or some size assumptions
on our formula if you want to kinda
debate this and this is what we're going
to do in this talk we studied the model
of Friedman's polynomial so like Rafael
mentioned everybody should know it by
heart but I'm going to define it every
way anyway so it's a polynomial that can
be expressed by a formula over each
variable appears at most once okay so
that's the definition and in a sense
these are the simplest polynomials or
the smallest that depend on all the
variables right if you think about that
and it's clear from the definition that
such polynomials must be multi linear
just because you cannot have x squared
anyway so one example is this polynomial
X 1 X 2 plus X 1 X 3 so this is read
once well if you look at this
you may realize that x1 actually appears
twice but you can pull x1 out of the
brackets and get x1 times x2 plus x3 in
the bracket this will be a read ones
formula and by the same token you can
realize that this forums read ones
formula form are very very small and
there is a class of almost linear
polynomials for example this 3 variate
polynomial is actually not a read once
but it no me it actually is it an
exercise to see it by you can do it by
brothers but now we have more
interesting ways to do it but even that
polynomials right out of the gate so
that's that's the problem
black box p80 or PID in general for
advanced polynomials so the non black
box is easy it's trivial so we want to
look at black box so that's the question
what do we know
so using standard randomized arguments
which words ipil and so will show you
that there exist the hitting set of size
and force in fact most of the sets of
size 10 to the 4 will be the right thing
what have we here set so again it
suggests that there is a small hitting
set but like many as the results with
this flavor it gives us absolutely no
idea how to find it mean to find it and
to reiterate this point
we're looking for a hey in a big big big
haystack and we have no idea how to do
it which is again typical to lower
bounds right there everywhere but we
don't know how to find one so this is
again just follows the same the same
sign unfortunately so the point is what
do we know so up until up until recently
the best known saying the best known
algorithm for it once polynomials were
the generic one which is the two today
and boolean cube so you can do it and
the first line of improvement came in
the joint work was actually serious of
work with a mere Shilka about 10 years
ago so if we gave the first
sub-exponential time black box PID so
the first result actually enter the
square root of n and then they improved
to 10 to the log n so this is quasi
polynomial and this
we won't spoil yours and it really wants
formulas all rejoice polynomials
regardless of their size so if we form
always rate once each variable appears
at most once the formula can be at most
linear right so actually you can if you
count the exact size it's 2n it's at
most 2 n minus 1 right so it's like you
can always assume with sub linear sites
right so for this polynomials for the
black box this was the kind of the first
sub-exponential result now since then it
has been a big line but there was a lot
of development studying classes of which
are richer than lead wants polynomials
and there more mention of them so ever
fail mentioned it once a VPS and some
other classes so somehow nonetheless
even for all these richer classes there
were this quasi-polynomial barrier if
you look at all this reason they have a
big big body of work for bigger classes
the black box part is still
quasi-polynomial the non black box part
we can do polynomial many cases but the
black box is quite a polynomial for it
once a VP for example for all such of
thing so it's not probably not the most
important problem in the universe
however since the appearance of did I
kind then I talked to many of you here
we'll be trying to see if we can
actually get it all the way down to
polynomial not just pass a polynomial
but polynomial and this is why here I'm
glad to tell you that finally they were
able to do it in this work we actually
show that they have a heating set of
size n to the 4 for black box read 1 so
when one's polynomial so this is
matching matches the theoretical date
probabilistic belt
within your size so in general you can
show that if you have s you need like if
you enforce it could sub size s you need
s square and then there's all this for
field size so I mean you can probably do
it linear size I'm not sure but Ruby M
cube will still work I mean again it
depends it's like all of that right it's
open to the first yes questions so
that's the high levels let me tell you
the main results and the subsequent so
this is the main result they have to
exist the heating set and explicit
heating set of size n to the four
current ones well just as a side note
you can generalize it to somewhat more
general classes like PR OPP process
treatments foreign laws but don't worry
about that so this is like the main
thing and now two other immediate chorus
is one which is you can actually take
this and extend it to a reconstruction
algorithm so yesterday we had an entire
day talking about reconstruction
algorithm so what is the reconstruction
algorithm I give you a black box with
the read ones formula inside and I want
you to find the formula so it's
obviously supposed to be as at least as
difficult as PID so using previous
results from Bisutti a tail and joint
work with a miracle that were able to
it's basically plug and play if you can
do this you can kinda plug and play and
able to extend it to a deterministic
reconstruction algorithm by the same
token using another result from one of
the previous results were able to extend
the PID for a single one formula to a
PID of some so suppose we have a black
box which has some like a big plus gate
and sums of read ones formula sum of
carry advanced formula so this is like a
black box like a plug-and-play result
that says that if you have AP 84 month
you can extend it to a sum of P 84 many
barring some constant overhead the
number of formulas so you just take this
and plug it in you get a heating set of
size n to the K for sum of K he read
ones formula so I'm not going to talk
about this result because the biggest
bulk of work will actually done in this
word
I'm quoting it's more like plug and play
so I'm going to focus on this which is
the novel but questions so how do we do
it
so the main notion when talk about vit
is the notion of a generator so what's a
generator generator is the polynomial
map that takes some stretches K
variables into n variables and typically
should think about K being like log N or
constant and we want to stretch number
of variable in the way that preserves
non zero nests so if you start with a
nonzero polynomial the new composed
polynomial is also non zero so this is
the object and why why would the
generators are going to be important so
you can always forget about what I said
and you can always do a PhD for any
polynomial in exponential size so you
can kind of the randomized where they
put in a trivial way and get a heating
set of size roughly D to the N so D
today and is polynomial and degree
exponential number of variables which is
not what we want however if we have a
good generator such that K is small and
the degree of the generators polynomial
all together you actually get quite a
nice heating set because the number of
variables goes to the exponent and in
fact the vast majority of the recent
work on blackbox p80 kind of follow this
path they show a generator for the
particular class of study and then they
get a small heating set right so and we
are going to do the same thing here and
in particular I would like to point out
so one generator that was actually
studying before and we kind of study it
again so this is the generator that we
defined in the work with Amir and this
is the following so this is essentially
what I call the Lagrange curve so we all
know what Lagrange interpolation
polynomials are so here actually using
them not in the algorithm a but in the
soul as the map so let me remind you so
we're going to fix and field elements
this thing filled the living isn't
matter what they are so for them you can
have what's called the Lagrange
interpolating polynomials mu I so what
review I if you take mu I and plug alpha
J it's going to be one if and only if
alpha I I equals J right this is kinda
matching if I equals J
then it's one if I doesn't apology it's
a zero right so this is a standard tool
used in many interpolation so again here
don't think about them algorithmically
think about the map right
so with des polynomials we can define
sort of the one the plane level of the
generator which is the G and one so it's
the end variable level one generator so
it depends on two variables it stretches
two variables into n variables in the
following way
so the ice component of this generator
it's basically the ice Lagrange
interpolating polynomial scaled by Z
okay mu 1 Sigma 2 Z and so on so this is
the one level G and one and now the more
elaborate construction the T levels the
T's level so G and T it's basically
taking team dependent copies of that or
taking this and summing it up G times
over fresh copies of variables such we
don't worry about that because we mainly
be talking about it but this is just a
generic way to the more generic thing so
we define that these polynomials and and
the same paper we showed that G and
Logan hits read once polynomials so this
was this sub-exponential result so timed
again going back to heating set so if
you have G & G in your polynomial then
the heating set the something like m2 DT
so here we have n log and this is how we
get the quasi-polynomial heating set so
this was the result and subsequently
this result was actually this particular
result was reproving and generalized
again for our OAB piece and many other
models that generalized
generalized the advanced polynomials
that but they all had the same log and
issue it was just log N or log n plus
something that hits the class and I mean
that was always good news that we had
some exponential PID but the question
was can we do better so if I guess if I
have time I would like to share a
personal story here so I was presenting
this particular work and talking about
this particular result during my PhD
thesis committee
giving the proof in the conclusion and
one of the committee members asked me
well okay it works for Logan can you
show limitations of this method can you
show that you know Logan works but log
Logan doesn't work Oh spirit event
doesn't work alone and five doesn't work
with something like that I said well
that's a good question
I have to think about it and well and
then I don't know the answer well and
then he told me well come back next week
so don't worry I passed the exam but I
came back next week and I said I tried
log log n square root of n I even and v
I couldn't find an example of a single
read once polynomial that vanishes on G
and v I couldn't find so then we said
together and try to G and for J and
three and pretty much all the way down
to G and one and we couldn't find a
single example of a read once polynomial
that vanishes on this and at some point
the kind I abandoned this and kind of
moved on but I was thinking about this
own kind of one enough but at this point
of time actually know why we failed why
we failed to find a counter example and
this is because of the following result
G and one is the heating set for
advanced polynomials this is what we
proved in this paper it would have been
surprising if they found a counter
example you know but I'm glad to again
react test that mathematics is
consistent this is the main result of
that paper that G and 1 so this first
level of the generator actually is a
generator for all read ones polynomials
and again you can talk
you can generalize it a little bit but
I'm not going to talk about it now
questions so in the remaining time I
would like to talk as much as possible
how we get this and I think that's it's
interesting on one hand on the other
hand it was a little bit of an oversight
of what we did here so it's like with it
or out that we kind of neglected a few
things here and here it kind of
resurfaced again so high level idea you
know this is what's called let's add an
injury to an insult let's look at
another place that
which is homogenous read once
polynomials so not already read once the
restricted make them even more extracted
right so how much of us polynomials I
guess you all know it means that they
have all the same the monomers have the
same degree so the first thing we show
is that G + 1 is actually a generator
for homogeneous advanced polynomials so
at this point all of you should be
laughing and be completely sort of okay
more trivial than that well it turns out
that this actually helps us it helps us
in the following way so it turns out
that in general read ones polynomial has
actually a homogeneous to advance
polynomial embedded in it so if you take
period read once per you're gonna take
the top slice all the monomials of the
higher degree it turns out that this
itself is a homogeneous advanced
polynomials and this is by the way not
true for many other circuit classes for
example for it twice is not true right
if you ever read for a B piece I'm not
sure if it's true so it's not true that
if you take a particular slice you get
the same mono but it through who read
once polynomials so like yes and put
together we get the following fact that
G and one is the generator for all great
ones polynomials how because you take
one and then you find the homogeneous
once you hit that and then you hit
everything correct so there are some
technical work is how you sort of
separate it but it's something like we
can do it very very easily so the
biggest bulk of work is this is how do
we actually hit homogeneous advanced
polynomials what I'd like to be able to
say a few words about so the idea is
again let's recall what we're talking
about so this is the set alpha I that
were that the set of distinct elements
that we use to define the generator so
the generator I remind you is this scale
of language interpolating polynomials so
kind the way we work is we proceed by
the structural structural induction
looking at this advanced polynomial so
this is all read once but you know not
have this structural induction this is
the homogenous version so take any read
once polynomial that depends on at least
two variables it
can be written in one of two forms
either a product of two advanced
polynomials or a sum such that P 1 and P
2 are variable disjoint and non constant
and if you think about this kind of
follows of the definition take your
formula what's the top gate plus your
here multiple plus you're here
multiplication you're here right and
this is a read 1 so everything is
disjoint so this is how it is you can
also get same type of lemma for
non-homogeneous but how much is actually
more interesting so this is what we do
we show that G and one hits it once
polynomials by the structural induction
so before there is a case we need to
handle which is the case of one variable
or more generally linear form so just I
want to show you this case just to
demonstrate one intuition behind the
choice of G 1 so suppose we have a
linear form looks like that a
homogeneous linear form without the
constant here actually it doesn't matter
what so suppose suppose it's suppose
it's nonzero so what can we do is it how
can we hit it so if it's nonzero it
means that one of the C is nonzero so
what we do is we're going to take this
polynomial and fix alpha to be Y to be
alpha I the same C I which is nonzero
and now I want you to see what happens
what happens if you take this Lagrange
interpolation and fix it to Y hi only
the eyes coefficients survive everything
else is zero right so it's like plugging
0 0 0 everywhere and 1 in the eyes
position right this is how Allah grant
works and here they're scaled by this so
you don't just plug 1 you plot Z
basically so if you the result of it is
that this is the only thing that
survives so it's C I times Z and this is
nonzero by definition so this is this is
a proof that G and one hits linear forms
so again this is something that was
actually known before and utilized in
many words but this is I think one of
the I guess the motivations how we chose
it to be ok so this is takes care of the
base case now what happens more
generally more generally in one of these
two cases so the easier case is the
multiplicative case when P is the
product well in this case essentially it
comes for free don't have to do anything
why because P 1 and P 2 are variable
disjoint means that P 1 and P 2 balls
depend on less than n variables right so
by inductive hypothesis G hit balls p1
and p2 and now you take a product of non
zero right that's it
as I've said comes for free I didn't
even use any property object but as I'm
sure all of you know there is no such
thing as free lunch of your breakfast
you have to pay for that right and the
payment comes in a deferred way talk
about the additive case and this is the
main technical contribution of the paper
how we deal with that so they did if
case let me show you how it works so
just for simplicity let's recall what
this are so there are Dutch
interpolation polynomial are just
product of these terms y minus IJ there
is some constant but I'm going going to
ignore it so let's look and see what
what happens if we look at fee which is
the product of all the terms so not just
this all the N terms Y minus IJ and see
what happens
so the main technical contribution which
I like to view as a inversion lemma
it's the following so let me read it
suppose I have a sum of two variables
each during homogeneous polynomials so
here by the way p1 and p2 don't have to
be read one just homogeneous and
variable disjoint such that P one
depends on B variables P two depends on
n minus B variables so the question is
what happens when I plug in this
polynomial this polynomial fee and this
is what happens you get some interesting
structure so first of all you get this Z
to the D F to the D minus one kind of
pulled out and then P one results in
this interesting saying so it results in
a polynomial which is the product of the
variables that P 2 depends on and P 2
results of the product of the variables
correspond to the indices of P 1 this is
the inversion part and on top of the
addresses p1 Prime and p2 Prime there
are polynomials but the point is P 1
Prime depends on the degree of P 1 prime
is less than the number of variables of
P 1 and the degree of P 2 prime is less
than the number of variables of P 2 so
it's inversion and decrease in degrees
okay so this is it so once we have that
it
kinda one becomes a one-line proof so
suppose I am a negative case I have P
and equals p1 plus p2 which are
homogeneous treatments polynomials and
suppose for contradiction and this is a
zero when I plug it so what it means if
this is a zero of this whole sum should
be zero so this thing's here are non
zero I can take them away and I get the
fact that this term equals this term now
the other point is P prime when t2 Prime
they emerge from P so pegged acting
hypothesis these two components are non
zero so what do we have left and now it
is that this two are disjoint because
they are disjoint indices it means that
this part here has to divide p1 prime
but that's a problem why because there
are B components here and the degree of
P 1 prime is less than B which exactly
finishes that's it so that the questions
I was able to do the proof do I have 20
seconds just one thing I would like to
say so this technical lemma is one of
these things is if I give you an
exercise to prove that thing it will
probably take you last a minute but the
biggest difficulty is finding the right
thing finding this right structure
finally that this is what we need right
but once I told you go do this plug it
in and do it it will take you an
exercise but this was kind of the
biggest BALCO 4 so I actually hope that
it will see light of day more because it
doesn't assume anything about Reid ones
except these two have to be disjoint
that's the only assumption here so to
wrap up we gave a first black box
polynomial-time PID algorithm for
advanced formulas and which can be
extended to the construction algorithms
for the same class of formulas and of
course the next question is can we do
the same thing for other so for each
case so as I mentioned all the
generalizations that followed that
result they all hit this
quasi-polynomial barrier was like n to
the log N or and
the logo and plus something so can we
get rid of that so for example we had
the subsequent work with Matt and dieter
in which we gave a capacity polynomial
black box PhD I'll do before each case
for more so again it's quasi-polynomial
so can we get rid of this quasi part
somehow and just like to make it even
simpler to start with can we get a
polynomial time algorithm for three
twice formula so this is the kind that
connects again as I've said I would be
glad to see the applications of this
inversion lemma in the future so that's
a good question so this is if you there
was a comment if you remember that
sometimes you need your feel allow
extension feel so this is kind of
tangent to it so if you if you want to
stay within like GF two you can actually
show by accounting organize you cannot
do it if you want any heating set for it
once polynomials of GF 2 will have to be
AB exponential size so this is one of
the things you have to you have to make
make the case that your field is large
enough your field has to have at least
and distinct points for example you
cannot define the J this particular
generator for that so in general if your
field has less than n or something like
that points you cannot have efficient VI
a black box baat just by counting
arguments
any other quick questions thank you